all right boys at LAX right now about to
fly to Gravedigger Mountain 8 hour
notice and now we're here so we're going
to go hang out with one of the most
prolific rappers of our lifetime in Utah
right now LAX by the
[Music]
way all right we made it great bigger
Mountain we're in Utah shout out to a
young boy who's uh currently on a horse
I to roll up on us you already
[Music]
know what's good brother up bro can I
say hi to you while you're on the horse
I'm I just don't want to get kicked may
I cut the horse she cool hey you know
I'm an animal lover man so hey man it's
good to finally meet you bro thanks I
appreciate you uh having me out here bro
for real that means a lot to me man so I
appreciate you for coming for sure it's
beautiful out here man welcome the gra
Digger Mountain you know I tried to find
a Gravedigger Monster truck toy for you
as a gift my son has a bunch and they're
all in storage I was going to try to
crazy I was going to try to I'm going to
send you one man what's the name of your
horse Tessa Tessa yeah Tessa how long
did it take you to get good at riding
the horse my grandfather used to take me
riding in eating okay kind of back that
way behind the M yeah I remember driving
through yeah yeah yeah that's dope was
it like a while to get the hang of it
cuz it's a wild animal when I got a was
pretty well trained right that's dope
man it's beautiful animal beautiful
animal I wish I could have had um a
dressed up for you her nails painted red
her hair d red and her tail red she
looks great bro yeah we kind of just got
in regular whatever do you have
different clothes for the horse yeah I
just what's crazy I just talked to shine
I'm trying to get a diamond everything
man oh that'll be crazy yeah bling out
the horse for sure one of one in Utah
it's my dog I love it man it's my second
child that I'm only on child support
for that's great that's what's up man so
how often do you ride uh like how often
do you take her out and ride her I
actually been up there going crazy
behind it man I've been focused on music
so much I ain't been getting to spent as
much time with him right and when I
brought it to uh my bro attention he was
like yeah I've been saying the same
thing that's dope so yeah you've been
busy man I know run just dropped you got
the Al that just dropped that was crazy
check this
out he say she been sticking her head
through the gate scratching oh [__] yeah
she been tripping bro oh she trying to
get out have you ever watched the uh the
TV show Yellowstone no okay it's about
it's about Cowboys in uh Montana yeah
and it got me interested in like horses
I play Red Dead Redemption that part two
man one of the greatest games ever yeah
it's long as hell it's so long Red Dead
Redemption did you play the first one
though know the OG one the new one is
great the last one was great but the OG
one is the one around that time I didn't
even have a game yeah that was when I
was a kid so I'm 36 so you're but you're
24 now right yeah yeah man this a
beautiful animal you have any dogs mhm
yeah I got all kinds of dogs man one day
I'll have a
horse one day I was going to buy another
one I just wanted to make sure I spent
like over two years with her first
that's smart yeah and also like you know
not for nothing a lot of people this is
like a you know they invest in horses
man
yeah that's crazy I was was just
watching TV and I've seen one horse bid
it at 1.7 million yeah in a man B they
invest you could you could invest in
race horses
um and then like these show horses man
that's the thing is like you can take
your horse to those those shows like the
RO the rodeos you know you're kind of
kind of like a cowboy this is cowboying
low key yeah I'm PTO Rock will nah this
this it's beautiful up here I see why
you're up here man yeah I love it I got
to get out of La
man um you not a ride that thing yeah
[__] we can figure it out turn around
all
right let's do
this uh I need to figure out how to
start it it's kind of like under your
leg at the bottom yeah it's a key at the
bottom I think it's on try to um try to
just hit uh is it on high or
low it's on medium it's on high now oh
oh yeah okay yeah yeah you got it in
reverse let's
go keep up
boys my
goodness
hey you said I was better than than I
than you were at first you way better
than me I can't come around that corner
like you're a good girl bro I love this
dog is this the first time the dog's
been around the horse yeah
oh
she thinks it's a big
dog why is you scaring her she's she's
she's
definitely she's she's eyeball you know
she's doing that the look leave that
horse alone BR she going to kick the
[__] out I think she's just genuinely
curious and if she's in
heat what's wrong I never saw that up I
mean imagine if you've never seen a
horse before and then you saw a horse
for the first time in your entire life
You' probably be like what the [__] is
that stop so you got a bunch more dogs
in Houston
yeah I have a cat too name neon what
kind of cat an actual cat yeah a black
cat oh [__] she like to come out here
and H do you ever see
yourself when you're able
to leave in
Utah like will this always be home for
you this will always be my
home I see why man it's beautiful I love
New York
too you like New
York come on he the horse is looking
right at this dog like I don't I don't
know what's going on with yo your phone
again I you want me to get it I'll grab
it
for
come that s
[Music]
crazy so this is always home yeah is
there um any
inspiration as to why Utah I have family
out here okay um I have a woman that
Christi me and brought me out to when I
was younger oh okay so it was always
like my dream to move here I grew up in
a city in Arizona called Mesa which is
kind of like a Mormon town kind of like
SLC I saw you kind of talked about the
latterday St faith is that something
you're still like following or
practicing or interested in I'm PTO Rock
so that's something you still kind of
like a part of or I never I was just
studying learning you studying it yeah
so you learned about like Joseph Smith
and a lot of that stuff yeah bring me um
bring me Mech bring me the Frenchie
shout out to Mac look at the little guy
he's got to be what like five months old
four months old I don't know he was a GB
oh someone who give who gives you a dog
like
that um it was actually like gu my my uh
dad
met that's dope shout out to your pops
is he uh he still incarcerated is he out
that's my biological okay Montana got
that dog for me oh fire it's got to be
cool to have your kids up here yeah this
is like I feel like this would be such
an awesome place to grow up like as a
kid you could go out play in the snow
I'm sure when it's not snowing it's
beautiful as well so much can do for
sure it's you'll never get bored there
always an activity to do and it's also
like you know if you're a a kid you're
so used to like not having a place to go
outside and play you're always on the
iPad at here it's like she got the lake
to go to she so much to do yeah Park
City you yeah you got the the snow sleds
and all that yeah you go to Park City a
lot n I've been inside going on three
three years the kids go without you yeah
they go a lot of places how long do you
have any end of date when it comes to
you know you being able to leave and
move around a little freely no damn I
get to go to the uh Cemetery in the lake
sometime oh that's good I mean you made
the the best of it man I was going to
ask you man like you you're still
putting out music at such a high high
rate uh I love the run record you just
dropped that [__] is hard man I I'm I'm
a [__] animal right now boy they play
with my name like I like I ain't that
thing say I've been wrapping my ass open
there Jason you won't tell them about it
but no man like listen obviously dude
like you're you're stuck here right
so I can only imagine like does riters
block happen does a lack of inspiration
happen sometimes or is this just you're
just always dialed
in behind behind behind this music [__]
I turn into a lunatic I Creator story to
talk about I like that
yeah they ain't never no D moment I like
that man sometimes you got to create
your own uh inspiration yeah cuz you
record yourself as well what is your
vocal chain for like the Geeks out there
is it what what's your compressor your
pre your mic what is like what's what's
the the vocal chain I don't know he just
he blessed me with the template and I
just go you just go in and record
yourself yeah so important man obviously
recently you said people been testing
your name when something like that
happens let's say like the Joe Buton
situation does that put even more of a
battery in your back to just shut
[__] up that I really feel like
that was just a it's just entertainment
it's a plat twist right like after that
we supposed to do an interview okay take
that serious it was just it was it at
certain point in times you kind of
understand you're entertaining the fans
you're entertaining the narrative
without it taking it to a place he's I
think he's somebody who study the game
he stud he studyed the music and and
[__] right I think it was just to get me
talking it worked it worked it's so
crazy um I feel like you've been so
successful despite kind of
being as anti- quote unquote industry as
possible and I mean that in a in a
positive way cuz I feel like most
artists they do their best to try to
play the game they do their best to try
to show up and show face go to events
hang out in La go to Grammy parties none
of that [__] has ever mattered to you
you've always been very authentic uh
when it comes to just the relationships
you have with the artist the features
you do I tried playing a game before but
that [__] don't work for nobody like me
I guess then another thing I don't want
to get caught up in all that now the
industry [__] it will consume you man
I've seen it happen with a lot of people
yeah and even like with the fans like
man you got to learn you you just
entertainment you're bad you're you're
moving is either a good one or a bad one
and you going to get called out that's
true and that's I think most people need
to understand that that's what this is
yeah like man you just entertainment you
got to know when the jok's on
you it's crazy cuz at a certain point in
time I started noticing young kids
having birthday parties themed after you
that's got to be as crazy as like seeing
a grownup with with your face tatted on
cuz there's a lot of those actually seen
a kid themed after me I think I saw that
and that that [__] me up
man how'd that make you feel I never
knew it was that
serious it's that serious man your fans
are are I would say probably the most
committed Bunch but I think that is I I
appreciated the fact that you're
starting to kind of be self be like you
know what like there aren't it's that
serious for a lot of kids at this point
it's really strictly entertainment yep
like it's hard being a person that you
want to be dealing with these people or
that you trying to be especially like
when you already like came in a certain
way it's crazy do you feel like because
of the way you came in there's like
what's the biggest misunderstanding
would you say people have about you cuz
people have there's a stigma about you
um that at times can be you know
positive and or negative but what what's
how are you misunderstood man cuz people
don't really get to know you you don't
do a lot of interviews
so I went to um I went to rehab for a
weekend Rec okay I still get a image
that I I do a lot of
drugs so I kind of get that thrown in my
face like oh he this taking over his
mind or something but at the same time
you don't know that
how recent how recent did you have to go
um Jason well two weekends
ago I think two weekends
ago and now I'm kind of taking on just
therapy from now on it's beautiful man
yeah was it uh cuz you know um I've been
doing a lot of Rich sipping and smoking
these nasty ass cigarettes cigarettes
will get you through some addiction I
mean it's another addiction but it's
obviously one that is a little bit uh
less less harmful yeah they been telling
my ass up though man I want to stop
smoking I'm so bad how's married life
been treating you man it's
great from I just got married uh in 2018
so it's all I feel like it's just
there's a certain piece at night when
you lay next to your wife you know yeah
on when I when it was first kind of
starting
out my my my vision was BL like just
blemished it's hard for me to trust for
sure but we've all been through
situations that taint our next
relationship and it takes a while to get
through those what I think what what
make me come to my sense is I pay
attention to who not here you know and
she put up [__] she put up with a lot
she except me for who you are hey what's
up I think she looks like she ready to
ride a horse
man I'm trying to uh B actually just
found a pony oh so I'mma purchase a pony
so you're going to have a pony and a
horse yeah you're going to have a zoo up
here eventually man man I want a uh
[__] alligator habitat that is very
bad and R
you for
sure to the bar and we
go never
wear dunks in the snow my feet are
[__] yeah I just took a piss at Great
dier mou my guy's got the old school in
the
barn that's what my car got I got
hydraulic on it that's that La [__] that
West Coast [__]
[Music]
n tell them we step like
Bigfoot
so K yo me and you think you want to
make a song I'm down let's do it now
when you say me and you make a song you
want me on the song yeah all
right we're going to go make a
song me a Bo man come on man we going
pop that [__] phone we're going to go
platinum today we're going platinum gold
for sure gold for sure okay gold for
sure that's mandatory that's too easy
for me
[Music]
I'm I'm I'm open to lay in a [__]
maybe four
bars little four bars you
know it's ghost
written you know what I mean hey
yeah we did not make a rap song that
didn't end up happening
not to say that it won't happen one day
cuz I did just get the invite back but
what we did do was we sat on the couch
we hung out and we shot the [__] for
about an hour and I'm excited for
everybody to see that
conversation and uh we're going to
release that
conversation next week thanks for
watching this Vlog though shout out to
NBA young boy man love that
guy just's try not to freeze to death
[Music]
all